oh you want your [ __ ] crazy story yes
please so sometimes I have a flaw where
I like to steal funder I'd like to be a
big wake I'm a large purse - yeah
so we have Georgia on my first kid and
and I start crying I get so emotional
that the doctor starts crying
anesthesiologist starts crying and they
take my camera from me and start taking
pictures of me with Georgia and then the
doctors is Jamaican guy who's like let's
go shorter grandparents and I was like
[ __ ] yes we walk out of the room a black
doctor domine
we go walk out of the room hit the
lights and they leave LeAnn in a puddle
of her own [ __ ] piss in the dark with
her [ __ ] badge just stitched uh she
is sitting there no baby no no not even
five minutes later now we're in her room
in her waiting room waiting for her
going where's LeAnn why is this thing so
long now mind you we've washed Georgia
we've dried Georgia we've given her all
her shots her inoculations we've taken
my grandparents out of the waiting room
gone into her room and we're waiting for
her I said I should look for I go back
to her room and she is shaking in a
pitch-black room with no one in there
just going go please go get somebody
oh dude I hope you told her to clean up
the doctor just asked woman you look
like [ __ ] awful fix yourself clean it
up I don't understand the diet I like
that's like a lawsuit the doctor just
correct know excited about you know the
machine that they turned off all the
lights and wow yeah everyone walked out
and left her there and there's a shift
change so no one knew she was in the
room oh yeah as [ __ ] crazy
will you shirtless in there my Oh
hilarious yeah I was so I was so selfish
during George's birth
you were right about you alright like
yeah yeah I was like I'm here to exam
acts like I but even the idea that you
would go and take the baby like I would
think of the mindset of like let me make
sure that Jess is taken care of when it
was happening and you were not at all
who it was like the idea that you would
take the baby here and like celebrate
with the grandparents and stuff and be
gone for four
45 minutes 45 minutes that makes no
sense
his shirts are we doing placenta shot it
hard for you to make it about someone
else in those moments yes in any way I
have a hard time
I don't recognize other people's
feelings a lot like I'm narcissists no
no you don't seem like well I'm not I
just I just get it I get excited and I
get overwhelmed and and I have a hard
time oh I have a hard time recognizing
other other people no see you tend to in
those moments you like it you like steal
a moment I don't even know I'm doing it
right right right
like Bland's biggest problem with me
when we first started dating as we go on
double dates and I did not let other
people speak
whereas I'm also really good reading
people and so I'm like oh she's [ __ ]
crazy like I don't want to hear what she
has to say and then my was really you
need to let her talking and this girl
Emma we went to dinner with them twice
and the next time I let her talk in the
middle of it she started crying at
dinner and I was like I [ __ ] told you
it should in my show right like yeah I'm
not gonna improv either like you steal
it oh I'm really good at guys name a job
fireman okay name is scenario waiting's
our bus yeah there you go
hey quick bring me a hose these children
are burning guts go well yes thank you
thank you very much holy hell actually
happened it was funny it was topical
realist